astro is known for its high-end gaming
headsets but with the a-10 not only do
we get a more budget-friendly option we
get something that's nearly unbreakable
however through my time with the a-10 I
found that it comes up a bit short in
some important areas this particular
model is branded for the Xbox one and
models labeled for the ps4 and PC are
also available but there's pretty much
no difference between them other than
color accents they all connect through a
3.5 millimeter chord so they can be used
on any device with a 3.5 millimeter
audio jack the package we received also
came with the m60 mix amp attachment
that allows you to balance chat and
ingame volume which is an xbox exclusive
while the headset itself is relatively
cheap at 60 bucks the big stamp would
add another 40 if you so choose the
biggest draw of the a-10 is that they're
built to withstand harsh conditions its
frame bends and twists without
compromising the headsets integrity you
wouldn't need to worry about any parts
breaking when putting them on or taking
them off since it offers incredible
flexibility so while the a-10 is the
most durable headset we've used they're
not exactly the most comfortable
especially if you have bigger ears the
ear pads are simply too small and press
on my ears which is disappointing for an
over the ear design it's unfortunate
because like Astros top-of-the-line 850
the a-10 has plushy velour earpads that
could have made it one of the more
comfortable headsets available if there
was more room for your ears in terms of
sound quality there's more to be desired
Bay shines through in games and music
but voices tend to come out distorted
even at medium volume levels the more
you crank up the volume the more
noticeable it gets when playing halo 5
guardians I could hear all the action
happening around me and deeper
explosions felt like they had weight to
him but many of the guns and voice lines
sounded like they had some crackle and
lack of clarity this shortcoming was
more apparent when listening to music
especially in hip-hop tracks where vocal
clarity is paramount the same holds true
for electronic songs with high-pitched
synths and Punk tracks with distorted
rhythm guitars as for the microphone the
output quality isn't bad at all it may
pick up some outside noise but you'll be
clearly understood on the other end
the microphone shares the same
flexibility as the headsets frame and
swings up and down so you wouldn't need
to worry about it snapping off overall
the Astra 810 misses the mark on some
important aspects I'd also keep in mind
that the a-10 is an entry-level headset
so if you're coming from TV speakers or
simple earbuds you're getting an upgrade
but compared to headphones and some
gaming headsets around the same price
tier the a-10 doesn't match up as well
we recently reviewed another gaming
headset the Logitech G 433 so I highly
encourage you check out that video we're
constantly diving into tech that drives
the games we love so subscribe to our
channel here at GameSpot for more
coverage thanks for watching